des images de l'organisme équiterre qui
a remis une pétition signée par 80 dix
mille personnes pour bloquer le projet
de pipeline énergie est équiterre qui
fait partie des intervenants entendus
lors des consultations publiques qui se
tenait aussi aujourd'hui on fait donc le
point sur les engagements des différents
partis politiques au cours de cette
campagne électorale mathieu il faut bien
précis que d'abord bonjour bonsoir faut
bien préciser qu'il ya deux projets qui
concernent en ce moment la région de
montréal deux projets très différents
puis c'est important effectivement de
bien les distinguer on va commencer par
ça le premier projet françois c'est
celui d'anne bridge le fameux pipeline
quand vous entendez parler puis 9 b et
bien c'est celui ci c'est un pipeline
qui existe déjà mais non le pétrole
coulait 2 montréal vers l'ontario
britos faire fait renverser le flux et
amener le pétrole des sables bitumineux
vers les raffineries de l'est de
montréal
mais le projet qui suscite le plus de
crispations
c'est celui de transcanada qui s'appelle
énergie est trans canada c'est quoi ça
va représenter 700 km de nouveaux
pipelines rien qu'au québec
alors si on retourne à notre autre carte
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire deux
pipelines les tracés ne sont pas encore
définitifs mais deux pipelines dans la
couronne nord de montréal alors que
disent les parties à ce sujet là eh bien
ces trois contre deux sur cette question
là on va commencer par écouter ceux qui
sont pour le projet energy est le
gouvernement soutient les projets qui
mettent nord aux os naturel sur le
marché et créer de bons emplois tant
qu'ils sont sans danger pour les
canadiens et sans danger pour
l'environnement ni héloïse espace
jeunesse
un projet comme énergie est va reprendre
en vertu d'un processus crédible et
complet c'est ça la différence entre eux
et nous alors eux dans l'esprit de
tomates mais terre ce sont les
conservateurs à qui il reproche avec les
libéraux d'avoir réduit les processus de
vérification environnementale sur cette
question là on voit ici des manifestants
ça c'était à québec
arrières thomass mal caire quand il en a
eu plusieurs fois des manifestants comme
ça durant ses déplacements pourquoi
parce que cette question des pipelines
c'est quelque chose qui tiraille un peu
le npd il ya quelques militants
notamment qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi thomas mulcair s'est opposé à
un autre projet ça c'était en colombie
britannique qui s'était fermement opposé
à of the gateway mais pourtant il est
pour nrj est alors question dans les
rangs du npd côté des libéraux c'est
sensiblement la même ligne ont dit oui à
énergie est mais à condition qu'il y ait
un strict processus de vérification
environnementale
petit bilan donc réponse à cette
question êtes vous en faveur de la
construction d'un nouveau pipeline dans
l'est du pays
c'est oui pour les conservateurs le npd
et les libéraux et il je serai pas un
nécessairement l'ambivalence mais
disons-le halal le contraire entre
l'appui du npd pour un projet pas pour
l'autre
c'est l'argument principal du bloc
québécois contre les [ __ ] il est
exactement le bloc québécois qui lui est
farouchement contre tout comme les verts
et c'est clairement un argument de
campagne pour gilles duceppe et
effectivement ils décochent des flèches
à l'endroit de tomas smolka on l'a vu
d'ailleurs très récemment avec une
publicité qu'ils ont mis en ligne où on
voyait un pipeline qui déversait du
pétrole pétrole qui se transformer en
niqab c'est autre chose mais que dit
gilles duceppe sur cette question là
c'est que ce pétrole est un pétrole qui
n'est pas produit au québec évidemment
il est produit en alberta pétrole des
sables bitumineux il n'est pas raffiné
au québec puisqu'il est dix thèmes
destinés à l'exportation
alors le québec n'a rien à y gagner
selon gilles duceppe on peut écouter ce
qu'il avait à dire là dessus c'est du
pétrole qui est transporté à travers le
québec pour être exportées et on prend
tous les risques environnementaux cas
pas entendre le québec qu'il pense pas
loin si valve c'est là que ça rapporte
taxes en actes
du côté des verts évidemment c'est
l'argument environnemental qui prime
on sait que ce projet là devrait
franchir 250 cours d'eau dont le fleuve
saint-laurent on peut regarder quelques
exemples de dégâts récents liés au
pipeline ça c'était en alberta en
juillet une brèche dans un pipeline tout
neuf c'est un pipeline de nexen 5
millions de litres déversés ou encore le
mois dernier c'était près de moscou
l'explosion d'un pipeline qui
franchissait justement une rivière alors
pour le bloc et le npd c'est assez
claire c'est non
le pardon pour le bloc et les verts
c'est non à ce projet d'énergie est donc
le bihan françois là dessus c'est que en
fait les trois partis qui pourrait
prendre le pouvoir après le 19 octobre
sont pour
par contre les deux qu'ils essaieraient
d'avoir le levier à la chambre des
communes
eh bien ils sont contre mais qui espère
avoir la la balance du pouvoir
merci merci beaucoup maintenu